In our last video we studied that plants have
two types of tissues.
Can you name them for me?
What are they called?
Dividing tissues and non-dividing tissues right?
Absolutely correct, now let us look at the
technical terms for these tissues.
In this lesson, we will look at the former
type of tissues.
The dividing tissues in plants are known as
MERISTEMATIC tissues.
Where does the word ‘meristematic’ come from?
It comes from the Greek word
‘meristos’ meaning ‘divided’.
Well, the main function of this tissue is
to divide and help the plant grow.
So where do you think you will find this tissue?
Exactly! They are at all the places where
the plant's parts show growth.
And as we just studied, all the parts of the
plant DO NOT show growth.
Growth is restricted to only certain parts of the plants.
What’s interesting is that meristematic tissues
is named differently based on the part
where it is found.
And do you know how many such parts of plants
have meristematic tissues?
Three different parts.
That’s correct!
Three different parts have meristematic tissues.
The meristematic tissues in each of these parts
has different names.
Let us look at the three main types of meristematic tissues.
The first is the ‘APICAL MERISTEM’,
the second is the ‘LATERAL MERISTEM’
and the third is the ‘INTERCALARY MERISTEM’.
Do not be let down by these difficult names.
Let me make them easy for you to understand.
‘Apical meristem’ tissues are found in
the growing tips of the STEMS and the ROOTS.
This tissue divides and helps increase the
LENGTH of the plant.
What about the second one,
‘Lateral meristem’?
Do you know where it is found in the plant body?
The word lateral means ‘side to side’
and this means the ‘GIRTH’ of the plant.
The ‘lateral meristematic tissue’ divides
and increases the girth of the plant.
‘Apical’ increases the length and ‘lateral’
increases the girth.
This girth of the plant is also known as the
CAMBIUM of the plant.
What about the last tissue type,
Intercalary?
Where is this tissue found?
This tissue is found at the base of the leaves
or the internodes.
These spaces here are known as the nodes.
What do you think this tissue will do?
They will facilitate the growth of the twigs
into branches.
As these tissues are VERY active,
the cells in these tissues are filled with CYTOPLASM.
They require a lot of energy and nutrition
to carry out the various functions of the tissues.
But do you know something interesting?
At the initial stages, these tissues are not
differentiated into any specific types.
Once they divide and mature after completing
the growth of the plant, their characteristics change.
Then they are differentiated into components
of a single tissue.
Division of labour takes place only after maturity.
Until then, all the meristematic tissues exhibit
the same function of ‘simple growth’ of the plant.
If these are the characteristics of the dividing tissues,
what about the non-dividing tissues?
Let us study them in our next lesson.